I'm so glad you're asking me  Jennifer Coolidge set the record  straight after joking about getting a  lot of sexual action on American Pie I  got some scotch single malt aged 18  years  the way I like it  earlier this year the White Lotus star  told variety that had it not been for  the movie she wouldn't have gotten quote  a lot of play at being a MILF and slept  with 200 people now speaking with Ariana  Grande for entertainment Weekly's  entertainers of the Year cover the  actress clarifies I did make the  terrible mistake of saying thank God for  that movie I got to sleep with 200 men  or whatever and look I would love to say  that it was true but I mean it was sort  of an exaggeration exaggerations aside  Jennifer reveals that playing Stifler's  mom did open up the dating pool adding  it did sort of open up the world to a  much broader group of handsome men and  younger men for more on entertainment  Weekly's entertainers of the year go to  ew.com  [Music]  foreign